our talking point today we are
discussing whether the indian simpsons
character apoo
is racist that debate started after a
producer on the show suggested a poo
would be written out because some people
feel he is a racial stereotype but now
one of the original writers is kart
stout on these claims
tweeting that the producer who made the
suggestion doesn't speak for the show
well for those of you who don't know the
character here's a quick introduction
you're like the guy you're a legend
around here guys is it true
you once worked 96 hours straight well
yes
it was horrible i'd tell you by the end
i thought i was a hummingbird of some
kind
oh yeah you know i studied your old
security tapes
there you go that is a poo this morning
we're asking
is that character that you saw there on
your screen racist joining me ash sarkar
senior editor at navara media and manic
govinda who is a writer
and arts mentor and who has his free the
springfield one t-shirt on
in support of a poo this morning um
it's interesting ash apu has been part
of the citizen since it started back in
1990
is the character racist so i'm not one
of those people that thinks that if
you're south asian and you like the
simpsons that you must hate yourself on
some level because it's so racist
because of the character of
i don't take that view what i think is
that comedy has changed a lot in the
intervening nearly 30 years so
while in 1990 when there's a dearth
of south asian comedy writers or actors
you know this idea of hank azaria a
white guy giving the voice to apu yeah
it's kind of funny but
nearly 30 years later the writing feels
a bit lazy a bit stereotyped and it has
had some negative real world effects
on south asian people so there have been
many times where i've left the pub
or you know been walking down the street
and someone's done the apu voice just
yelling it at me um and that's clearly
not the
writer's intention of the simpsons i
mean the simpsons has
i think enriched all of our lives in
some way it's a as a cultural
institution and long may it continue to
be so
but i think it is definitely time for a
change manic do you think it is a
lazy crude stereotype or actually does a
poo as a character have more depth
than that he's got a lot more depth than
that um i mean he has an indian accent
you know and so many people
immigrants from india who work as
shopkeepers who
opened uh small businesses have an
indian accent so there's nothing
stereotypical about that that's that's
reality
i think he's got a lot more depth what's
wonderful about apu is that he really is
a
kind of blue-collar immigrant american
hero i think
um excellent degree qualifications
um he did arrive as an illegal immigrant
but then naturalized to become
an american citizen so he holds this
dual
identity of being indian and american
quintessentially both and
i think very much part of the community
the simpsons he's made good friends
there that's why i decided to stay in
the
in the community yeah that is a very
positive light a poo is painted in he's
hard-working he got his u.s citizenship
he loves america
he loves his job he works hard is that
is that not a positive take there people
to watch the simpsons look at a poo and
go
well yeah actually he is a positive
image
of southeast asia and immigrants i mean
i absolutely don't think that this
character has been written
out of malice right i'm not an apo
truther by any stretch of the
imagination
but in some early interviews from the
90s when hank azaria is talking
about how he came up with apu's accent
he says like i just wanted to make it as
offensive as possible
and so that indian accent and you know
lots of people in my own family
when you look at all the other
characters as well you look at the the
police chief you look at the local
politician
look at homer simpson himself you know
the caricature of middle america big pot
belly
beer guzzling and you know a bit rough
with his son
the difference is that that's not going
to have real world effects for people in
the same way because like i said the
character of apoo
is written when you don't really see
very many other images
of south asians particularly in america
and i think
now after we've had the mindy project
after we've had the career of
um you know hari kondabulu and others
we've got different expectations of our
comedy okay so in that sense then
manic how can we modernize a poo rather
than get rid of him because then you
won't have any
representation on screen at all does he
need to be updated
all the characters in the simpsons have
not aged over the last you know nearly
30 years
so um it doesn't feel i mean they they
are frozen in time in many ways although
they respond to a lot of contemporary
would always die down if it was an
indian actor voicing a poo
well um i mean you know hank uh is
is a great voice actor you know he's an
award-winning voice actor and he does a
number of characters
i think we should you know if he wants
to do it and if the simpsons producers
want to keep him that they they should
keep he
has said that he's open to the voice
actor being changed and another thing
that he himself has suggested is
diversify the writer's room
i've been blessed enough to work in a
writer's room a couple of times
and when it had a range of people from
different backgrounds people were firing
on all cylinders
you had really smart really funny you
know really on the nose comedy writing
in that kind of situation okay
so this was a point that was made by
somebody on twitter yesterday what is
the difference between a poo in the
simpsons
and a british comedy like goodness
gracious me
where they have very strong accents and
the whole
indian culture is overplayed and they
poke fun at themselves what what's the
difference
for me it's a very different thing when
you are making fun of your own culture
and then you're showing it to
a wider audience because it's you being
in control of it
humor is a great uh means of social
cohesion people getting to know each
other but you can only do that when
it's someone of that background finding
the point of well
does that mean we can't make we can't
make fun of each other anymore
the worry is that um then you have to
basically stick in your own laying about
you know characters that you write that
you know i can only write about
an indian asian character because that's
my cultural background
that would really narrow creativity and
comedy
and art generally if we are only allowed
to
speak from our own experience or um make
fun of
our own cultures yeah and i would rather
you representing the fact that you know
he hasn't stayed in his own lane he's
come to america and explored that
culture and you know blended in
but do you think that if you had a
diverse writer's room for the simpsons
and you had perhaps a
south asian voice actor for apu that the
writer would get the writing would get
worse or better
i mean let's be real none of us have
enjoyed an episode of the simpsons after
season 9 season 10
if you're being generous this thing
about it being crazy frozen
you know frozen in time is that um the
writing has become more and more sort of
outlandish in an attempt to find
something funny and it's really i think
lost what made it great
and i think in an attempt for um this
like i said this pop cultural
institution which i love i wouldn't
watch anything else when i've got a
hangover
in order for it to be revived i think it
needs an injection of new blood
i mean actually you've amazed me there
because you're saying that everyone in
the writers room isn't yellow
which you know everyone in the simpsons
is i mean manic what is the answer
you know does the simpsons have to
conform because you've got other shows i
mean
it's a bit dated but it's from the same
era as the simpsons you've got south
park
which you know is massively offensive
and goes so far the other way you've got
other cartoons
that you know are more inclusive the
simpsons has its own little niche
yeah and i think the simpsons was
pioneering um
program it's it has you know opened the
doors for lots of other great
uh animation comedy writers um and um if
people want to create new characters
then let's
they should be pitching that to the
producers and to the tv stations and
looking for new stories i don't think
that
you have to kind of put everything onto
the simpsons show
um to um change uh representation
well one thing we can agree on is
hashtag saverpoo nobody wants to see the
at the end of a poo manikavinda and
asaka thank you very much